la intensa ola de calor no da tregua en
argentina una masa de aire cálido se
formó sobre el país en pleno verano
prácticamente la totalidad de argentina
y también países vecinos como uruguay el
sur de brasil y paraguay estamos
viviendo de las jornadas más calurosas
en la historia en argentina desde el
centro de patagonia hasta el norte del
país se están replicando valores
térmicos que están alcanzando o
superando los 40 grados en algunas zonas
del país el termómetro ha alcanzado los
45 grados celsius la falta de lluvia y
la sequía también afectó a los cultivos
con muchos días de cielo despejado de la
radiación solar es muy intensa y en un
contexto de sequía extrema argentina
hace aproximadamente 2 años que está
atravesando una sequía muy prolongadas
la ola de calor y la reactivación de la
industria ha venido acompañada por un
crecimiento de consumo eléctrico con
consecuencias como repetidos cortes
masivos que han afectado a miles de
usuarios en buenos aires y sus
alrededores la mayor demanda de energía
viene por parte de los grandes
consumidores que son las empresas y las
industrias que están participando en
este círculo virtuoso de reactivación de
la economía y que hoy solidariamente
van a hacer algún tipo de control para
refrescarse algunos habitantes de la
capital optaron por los juegos en el
agua mientras que otros se bañaron en el
río de la plata se cortó totalmente este
así que era insufrible tuve que irme a
un lugar donde donde había un poco de
refresco y además era muy complicada la
ciudad se espera una caída de las
temperaturas a partir de la semana
próxima y lluvias que refrescarán tanto
a la cera como a la gente